böse zungen meinen auch es wäre kopiert
oder so habe ich schon meine mutter fit
gelesen ich weiß nicht was ist eure
meinung dazu findet ihr das ist wie in
den campingtrip oft wo das von jump
geklaut oder ist es genug eigenständig
des spielmodus herzlich willkommen zwar
im neuen video heute probiere mal einen
für mich relativ neuen spielmodus aus
ich weiß nicht die wirklich neu ist oder
wie alt neu
der spielmodus jump wars und das ist ein
bisschen jump league nach empfunden habe
ich das gefühl böse zungen meinen auch
es wäre kopiert oder so habe ich schon
meine mutter feed gelesen finde ich
jetzt persönlich nicht so krass aber ich
möchte einfach mal die runde spielen und
mit euch meinen persönlichen eindruck zu
schwingen modus teilt und heute auch die
gewinner der verlosung bekanntgeben
es gab bei einer verlosung zu den nerv
ich habe so ein video gemacht ricken
gewinnspiel dazu und jetzt ist das
gewinnspiel vorbei und die gewinner ich
hab die bereits ausgesucht und ich werde
das jetzt im laufe dieses videos
einsenden kurze zwischenmeldung ich habe
mich dagegen entschieden dass im video
einzublenden das wollte dir auf twitter
auch nicht als ich dann eine abstimmung
gefragt habe deswegen gibt es die
ankündigung der gewinner des
gewinnspiels jetzt am ende des videos
genau
also wenn ihr wissen wollt wer gewonnen
habt dann das video zu ende oder springt
zu dieser zeit hier
da geht das gewinnspiel los und
ansonsten ist es ein ganz normales video
gemeinde so jetzt zurück zum gaming teil
des videos so also der allgemeine
spielmodus funktioniert so man hat dir
so einzelne module durch die man springt
und im laufe dieser module sammeln mal
kisten ein sodass erinnert vom konzept
her schon natürlich ein damm blicke der
modus jetzt nicht eins zu eins kopiert
das muss man zugute halten aber gewisse
ähnlichkeiten gibt es schon würde ich
sagen hatte den letzten stunden gameplay
drin da hatte ich eure zuschauer ihr
wisst schon was ich meine nicht eure
vorschläge zur presse button hatte ich
dann eingebaut und im hintergrund lief
genau dieses spiel und ich führen wird
momentan sogar aber hier geht es am
anfang nicht so krass abgezogen als ich
noch nicht kannte oh mein gott da wohl
ich hier so versägt ganz ganz ideal
mittlerweile geht es jetzt einmal die
module ein bisschen kennt kommen wir
ganz gut voran aber ihr seht schon die
anhaltend schritt und das ist ein
kleiner glücklicher lag hier
normalerweise müsste man reset werden
wenn man den lover oder wasser fällt ich
habe jetzt gerade eben auch ich habe
angefangen zu brennen
habt ihr gesehen aber ich wurde
glücklicherweise trotzdem reset finde
ich gut so da haben wir eine kiste ohne
respekt ist es glaube ich ziemlich
richtig kennen dieses motto hat noch gar
nicht mehr ziehe ist die keine ahnung
wie uli springer erwartet vielleicht
hier nicht auch hier ja hier so ja das
sieht gut aus
natürlich müssen kinder kommen jetzt
noch nicht da erst mal hier überholen
durch das tödliche wasser durch gut dass
das tier kenne ich wieder und ich habe
das gefühl wir holen gab ein bisschen
auf unserer konkurrenten nach vorne
ich weiß nicht was ist eure meinung dazu
findet ihr das ist wie den jump liege
rip off modus von jump geklaut oder ist
es genug eigenständig was meint ihr habt
ihr schon mal gespielt wie findet ihr es
würde mich mal persönlich interessieren
weiß das schon
böse zungen jetzt so geht's hier weiter
hier
alter schwede gerne wurde ja krass warum
wollte so krass reset wieso geht so was
hat unser konkurrent die runde verlassen
haltet vor uns als millionen verlassen
warum goal wie einen chat ausrastet
welchen punkt in chats schreibe ich bin
übrigens nicht gelegt in dieser runde
bisher seien ja so als kleiner
spielmodus showcase soll das hier gelten
also ich finde den modus auf jeden fall
witzig so angeht klar muss man sagen ich
weiß halt nicht ich weiß nicht wie ich
es beurteilen soll ob das jetzt ein jump
off ist oder nicht ja also es gibt viele
eigenständige elemente des pvp system
moment des anders pipapo probiert's aus
dem wallis national treten weil das ist
ja eher den spielmodus
dort wir haben jetzt auf jeden fall
kinos haben wir sehr schönes voller
rüstung stuff wir haben und die alle
haben ganz seltsame user so wir haben
jetzt hier finde ich sehr schön die
anderen ganz news ich glaube immer die
an seht ihr 60 dann wirft man die einmal
weg und ohne dass dem gegner damit
triffst verliert ihr automatisch user
das heißt du kannst nicht andere
klatschen ist ganz interessant
eigentlich ich habe hier früher immer
dafür eingesetzt dass die abgeschafft
wird viel users mit einem wurf nur mit
in die wirst so hat man halt den angel
spam vermieden weil ich glaube die
buddys auch so ein bisschen feinde von
experten sind die schauen weil wir uns
hier im dm schlagen was problem werden
könnte es das wert umgelegt sind es
könnte ein richtiges problem damit der
datagroup unter stecken comp mall als ob
er den kürzlich bekommen
okay ist eine andere
teilweise lag das hörbare noch richtig
krass teilweise dass man mitten im job
man einfach rettet wird alter verlaub
ich doch fast noch mal in den spaß rein
na los brennt brennt sehr schön blau
lässt instant immer zwei gegner dann hat
man kriegt ja auch ja man kriegt aber
entscheiden uns dann auf seine rüstung
wenn man hier in den gewisse anzahl an
kills macht man so jetzt des der iss
darunter ist auch lokal mega legt aber
auch kassel aber zog an ihm gesehen also
teilweise reset der server ein auch alte
positionen
was menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend ist aber es der spielmodus
wahrscheinlich ganz neues heim ist
glaube ich die buddys punkt net jetzt
mal all das gibt's doch nicht hinter uns
einer hin zu sein und über den wir das
überleben
mein gott aber um weiter also muss sagen
hast es ja ganz schön durch ne aber ganz
schön wir uns runter gezockt hat man
kriegt ob ich eine instant ihn
installieren wenn man jemanden kilt von
vier herzlich dass man mit instant viele
herzen gespielt wenn man jemanden
killers bisschen anders als bei bei jump
league aber gewisse parallelen bestehen
auf jeden fall kann man nicht sagen wir
abstimmen in kliniken
den klee note eins haben gehabt sehr
schön und jetzt ist der andere da noch
ein leben bei dem oralen leben das feuer
löschten die feuerwehrleute es geht
nicht aus sieht jetzt es geht auch nicht
aus ich kann es nicht ausmachen
fakt ist auf jeden fall trick jetzt ja
schlecht aussieht mit den coupons wollen
wir ihn ab blogs mails haben sie
verstanden alles lama gucke ob der
andere jetzt abstaubte ich weiß es nicht
davon halten soll haye hat er jetzt
schaut man ok damit am bng es ging in
anderen damit wir die runde jetzt nicht
allzu lang machen ready und jetzt sieht
eigentlich ganz gut aus hier jetzt ab in
den kampf wurde ich mir vorher kann ich
mit gm jetzt hier und dann alter schwede
ist der lohhofer acht kills 2003 am fels
sehr nice eigentlich die leute das war's
so weit von diesem test schreibt eure
meinung zu dem modus man die kommentare
in diesem sinne bis zum nächsten video
haut rein macht's gut
und ja und zwar seht ihr hier in youtube
random comment pk das ist ein tool das
zufällig im kommentare auswählt und wir
machen das jetzt einfach live damit
niemand sagt wir hätten getötet oder so
leute mal ganz ehrlich so unter uns
gesprochen
wir wissen nicht bei wie vielen
gewinnspielen von youtube und getötet
wird dass irgendwas einhalten wird er
war es passiert ziemlich oft deswegen
ist mir wichtig dass wir das hier offen
und ehrlich machen damit er genau sieht
okay alle packs die auch in der
beschreibung eingetragen sind werden
auch verlust und haben wir auch sehr an
wen es geht und deswegen tragen wir
zielen youtube-link zack das ist der
link zu dem schneemann video und dann
läge jetzt die kommentare und wir gucken
an denen das erste von vier standard
packs geht wir machen das telefon nach
oben erst ab excel panik cellpack an
drei tage später ok kommen jetzt
auswählen pick the most recent kommt
dass wir nicht so wir wollen randomly
pichorner sie wollen zufällig ein
kommentar aus wer gewinnt ok und das
erste von vier standard ecx geht
charlene alaska italienischer wer gesagt
ihr müsst einfach nur das video
kommentieren um an der verlosung
teilzunehmen sollte jetzt die neue
pflaster nicht wollen dann könnt ihr das
auch unter dieses video schreiben dann
ist es cool dann kriegt ihr mal anders
die da machen wir nochmal eine weitere
verlosung und verlosen die die jetzt bei
sie nicht akzeptiert worden und charlene
anlass du bist die erste von vier diese
standard pack gewonnen haben heißt zwei
von diesen kleinen grünen kittel mit
alles klar
aber wir brauchen noch drei weitere
gewinner für das standard pack deswegen
weil einem lieb ihr grüner simone bauer
jetzt alles klar gg
du kriegst auch zwei von den kleinen
zwei stück von denen zwei standard
gewinner brauchen doch simon luft leute
da sind wir die gail zuschauern haben
simon luft gratulation an dichte gewinns
auch im sommer pack mit zwei von den
kleinen okay ein gewinner braucht man
noch für die stadt pecs und dann geht es
weiter zu den xl packs nächste gewinner
der stadt pecs ist nächster und letzter
samuel wasilewski übrigens alle gewinner
die jetzt hier genannt werden unbedingt
unter diesem video kommentieren
unbedingt mir eine private nachricht auf
youtube mit eurer adresse schreiben und
kam durch die blätter nicht zu schicken
ganz wichtig unbedingt auf youtube eine
private nachricht an mich schicken
mit eurem account mit dem ihr gewonnen
habt und eure adresse schicken dann
kriegt die besten mit zugesendet wenn
ihr wollt signiert genau schreibt dazu
eure adresse und ob er dirigiert haben
wollt dann nicht und dann geht das ding
raus samuel wazir letzt gewinnt das
letzte von vier standard ecx und jetzt
geht es um zwei xl pécs ist und diese
orangen dinge mit denen wir auch im
video geschossen haben die hier
da seht ihr die genau es gibt jeweils
einen orangenen und noch mal einen
kleinen grünen dazu gibt es auch zwei
gewinnen also zweimal einen orangen und
einen grünen und der erste gewinner vom
xl ist riese gratulieren mir ist egal
welche und richtig heißes video alles
klappt auch du persönliche nachricht mit
einer adresse und mit seinem wunsch für
die signiert haben möchtest du nicht
also signiertes unterschrieben der
nächste gewinner und der zugewinn auf
dem mixtape ecke löst christoph kolb
die außenorte wollt dann alles klar
christoph gratulation auch an dich du
bekommst auch nichts opec du wirst schon
besiegt haben auch du persönliche
nachricht mit adresse dann geht der spaß
heraus an dicht und jetzt leute jetzt
geht's zu zum xxl projekt zu den
nominierten diesen ganz großen grünen
und jeweils nochmal kleine grüne dazu
also dass das größte pack wird schauen
wir wer hier am dicksten abgesahnt hat
wie wenn er noch mal eins der sco jannis
ttc 04 halt tatsächlich mit dem
kommentar sie wird die xxl pack gewonnen
gratuliere mein lieber das ist so ein
kommentar der können hier vorstellen
dass er vielleicht kann ja im schirmer
das überhaupt gewinnspiele oder diesem
video
falls du dem leiste haben möchtest mir
persönlich nachschauen wie seit adresse
und obduziert haben möchte sollte da
kein kommentar oder keine nachricht
kommen werden werden die packs noch mal
verlost wird sagen ich lasse den leuten
als eine woche zeit nicht an zu
schreiben sollte ja nichts kommen werden
die packs neue verlust okay und jetzt
das letze letzte xxl pack der große
grüne unter kleine runde ging an lena
tamara cicciolina tamara deine adresse
und dein wunsch ob wegen ihrer matches
oder nicht per pn das war es von der
verlosung jetzt habt ihr eine woche zeit
nicht an zu schreiben sollte da
innerhalb von einer woche nichts kommen
werden die x verlost das wasser weit von
der verlosung und tschüss